so I've got a question for you have you
ever called a company and been put on
hold and the worst part is you're
calling to cancel a service and it's
like they know it's like they know that
you are calling to cancel you would keep
you a little image of the damage the
phone table I know I won't call back
later you'll hang up I never call back
and then when those insert your swear
word of choice here actually do pick up
the phone will do everything in their
power to make sure you don't cancel that
that's service
hi yeah I wanted to cancel my sprint
service um yes it's easier that you go
destroyed a video card is that correct
yep that's it and I just want to cancel
it that's it just cancel it okay well
since you don't what the server sending
longer would you like to make expense
for the service to a friend um no that's
okay okay what about a distant family
member
hmm no that's fine okay maybe what about
a friends distant family member that
still no okay what about maybe like an
aunt or a cousin or maybe like I don't
know do you have any like some bad the
cat's
no I really just want to cancel it why
don't why do you say so in the first
place so let me just see what I can do
here okay you just be one now what I
just gotta I just have to punch in some
numbers here
[Music]
so basically you're gonna have to be
under $2 for the cancellation fee but we
can waive that fee if we can just maybe
like transfer the service to a fam now
at this point you might be getting a
little frustrated and you might want to
do a little something like this really
only another 50 because I paid $5.00 but
you can't really do that can you
well hardly particular reason that you
like to cancel the service today I
switched to Verizon oh really well hells
Verizon treating you great
oh they're treating you great it's just
wonderful well we're sorry to see you go
here it's print just another second here
guess what that continues on for another
15 to 25 minutes and I'll spare you the
rest of that dialogue has this ever
happened to you what were you trying to
cancel and what was the end result let
me know leave a comment below okay
Justin you're all good to go but just
one last thing
is it okay if I said you'll survey the
survey is a survey about customer
service surveys
[Music]